شدد رئيس وزراء ماليزيا انور ابراهيم على
ضروره وقف اطلاق النار في غزه مؤكدا ان
بلاده لا تتفق مع الموقف الامريكي بشان
القضيه الفلسطينيه وفي مقابله مع قناه
الجزيره مباشر قال ابراهيم انه ابلغ
الامريكيين ان على واشنطن ان ترفض استمرار
القتل في غزه مضيفا ان للفلسطينيين حقا
اصيلا في ارضهم وفي اقامه دولتهم ولا يمكن
ان يكونوا في سجن
مفتوح لدينا علاقات طيبه وقويه مع امريكا
نحن دوله ديمقراطيه وهناك نقاط مشتركه
ولكن بالنسبه للقضيه الفلسطينيه لا نتفق
معهم لا نتفهم الموقف الامريكي وبغض النظر
عن الاسباب يجب ان يتوقف القتل في غزه في
هذا العصر لا يمكن قبول ما يحدث في غزه
يجب ان نقوم بالدور المتوقع منا حتى لو
كانت هناك صعوبات ولكن ليس امامنا خيار
سوى ايقاف المذبحه في غزه r